long convoi de véhicules blanc s'élance
la mission de la kids kiev pour la
centrale nucléaire de zap origin le
début du travail et la fin d'intenses
préparatifs pour l' agence onusienne
nous sommes enfin en train de bouger
après six mois d'efforts acharnés
l'aï eu à se rend à l'intérieur de la
centrale nucléaire de zaporijia
comme vous le savez nous avons une tâche
très très importante à accomplir là bas
un peu plus tôt ce mardi le directeur de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique était reçue par volodymyr
zelinska le président ukrainien craint
que la russie n'empêche la visite de la
centrale
c'est une mission importante et nous
ferons tout pour qu'elle se déroule en
toute sécurité
malheureusement la russie ne cesse pas
ses convocations précisément dans la
zone que la mission doit emprunter pour
arriver à la centrale imaginaire que l'
ua pourra commencer son travail
la délégation du gendarme mondial du
nucléaire est encore loin de son
objectif situé à plus de 500 km au sud
de la capitale ukrainienne en plein sur
la ligne de front les russes qui
occupent la centrale depuis mars affirme
accueillir favorablement la visite de
leioa mais il accuse de nouveau kiev de
viser les installations nucléaires qui
ont déjà été momentanément coupées du
circuit électrique ukrainien la semaine
dernière les troupes sucré nien postés
de l'autre côté du fleuve dniepr
assurent de leur côté que ce sont les
russes qui procèdent à des tirs
d'artillerie aux alentours de zappos dia
en attendant kiev fait distribuer des
pilules diodes dans la zone et
entraînent ces secours à réagir à un
accident nucléaire